the nfl is back we're excited college
football is back and that's going to
lead me into our next category guys is
you got these two coaches that kind of
have in the past and one still does rule
just everything in their universe nick
saban in college at alabama and bill
belichick for what he's done in tampa or
in new england for the last two decades
you know it's fascinating because the
narrative is these two guys are so
similar right they have similar styles
they're no nonsense they're grinders
they're lifers their fathers you know
raised them a certain way that got them
where they are right now they're tough
they're
evolvers
and and they're champions i'm gonna tell
you this i think right now it is so
separated between the two i think bill
belichick has more to prove this year
than anybody in the nfl
it sounds crazy but i really believe his
entire legacy depends on what happens in
the next 17 games for one simple reason
and it's so obvious but you just cannot
get past the fact he has not been
successful without tom brady and not
only has he not been successful he's
been horrible if he kept up that winning
percentage that he's had without tom
brady he would be fired he would be out
of the league he'd be back to being a
defensive coordinator so
he's got so much to prove to the fact
that i think that he has his entire
legacy
20 plus years coaching in the nfl
one of the all-time winningest coaches
ever in the sport but really show me you
can do it for one season just one season
without tom brady then i might start
believing but i don't know phil am i
being too harsh to say that
i think uh seven and nine isn't i mean
it's not horrendous where we're asking
for is walking papers
you know i mean you do lose some
impactful players right
and
look it's
we're talking about super bowls we're
not talking about bcs championships
we're not talking about sec
championships i mean what saban's got
four and four right secs and bcs's which
is dope like yeah shout out to all the
guys in lsu you know my cousin trending
holiday played there i mean yeah you
know go
usually just beat lsu keep that in mind
yeah yeah you know but at the end of the
day i mean i you know that to me
super bowls matter
period i mean we just talked about how
difficult it is how hard is it if we're
talking about bama repeating
we say oh yeah like they could easily do
it yeah but to say that oh the patriots
can do it or the the buccaneers can do
it it takes a lot and we're talking
about recruiting you know kids kids are
going to say well i'm going to go to
bama because you know they have all the
resources they you know we're talking
about college yeah pro is a lot
different different personalities you
have a lot of the money
and who really wants to play in new
england yeah i mean
you know that there's a lot with that
players well it's boston players will go
where you can win and i think the exact
side almost anything else i mean the
weather might be great in jacksonville
but no one's running there i think it's
so impressive that uh you know anyone
that has a super bowl ring you know
what's funny
they don't lose those
there's been some players that may have
sold them because they lost their money
but
ask a player
where's the super bowl they're they're
doing this they're not doing that with
the bcs stuff they would trade all i i
would trade
a bcs for four bcs championships for one
super bowl period or the college
football championship as well absolutely
but you know what still college football
is huge he's at the top of the mountain
and he's the only person you can say has
a legitimate chance to repeat his
champion every single year we make it
sound like it's easy but it's not to do
what what nick saban has done and he's
done it because he's not afraid to
change his ways and evolve and and look
he just plugs in different quarterbacks
and they're all great tua mac jones now
bryce young and what's really ironic
paul is the fact that bill belichick in
my opinion who has his entire legacy on
the line this year is going to depend on
a former alabama quarterback who was
great last year at alabama but his
replacement is great and the two or
three guys before him were great so
there's a system there that quarterbacks
can fit into and if i'm bill belichick
and my legacy depends on this coming
season and it's a rookie quarterback i
need more than the fact that he's an
alum of alabama i i just i feel really
strongly about the fact he's got a lot
to prove as a head coach well and and
here's the other side of that right you
mentioned quarterbacks from alabama
they don't have a great track record in
the nfl there's not one off the top of
my head where i'm like oh man like
they're they're not quarterback you even
though they've gotten uh several guys
drafted but they're not they're not
necessarily translating unlike say the
defensive players and obviously the
receivers uh they definitely you know
create receivers out there but i don't
think bill belichick
has to worry about his legacy because
at the end they are also comparing them
to other people in the same
the same breath right like you talk
about bill walsh you talk about you know
uh george hales or all those guys pretty
much had their one quarterback that they
won the super bowl with bill walsh
didn't win another stream i think he
only had
bill walsh only had two or three yeah
but i'm super one with steve yeah but
i'm thinking as far as like when we talk
about bad seasons yeah it's been what
like it was they were seven and nine
last year right yeah were they seven and
nine i believe look
dave can you look it up look at the
patriots record from last year i don't
think they were that i don't think they
were seven well you might be right but
don't forget he coached at cleveland for
five years yeah he drafted in the middle
but my point is my point is how many
losing seasons in 20 years yeah has bill
belichick but there's the asterisks it's
because tom brady played there and you
mentioned george halas you've been for
20 years yeah but but those guys were
smart enough not to try to coach without
joe montana or whoever it might be i
mean they knew pictures won seven and
nine last year okay seven and nine in
the great job in the strange season
uh look
i think it's bugging the crap out of
bella check that out
yeah i agree with you 100 i mean look
when you're a champion and you've
experienced that
and you didn't for a while which the new
england patriots they did have a slump
right a so-called slump
and then they got back up there
you everything is championship or
nothing and that's why he kind of uses
like in business like let's say a
netflix like a reed hastings it's like
oh yeah we'll usually and then we'll
trade you we'll use it and then we'll
get rid of you like
sorry
i mean cam newton hey sorry man richard
seymour yeah there's a lot of guys that
we would say why would you do that but
it's he's looking at it from a different
lens and i am no guru when it comes to
football but
the results matter yeah and i am hoping
that
he does well obviously and i do agree
with you now that i'm thinking about i
mean legacies do matter and this is an
opportunity for him to
have those naysayers because look these
guys have
formed this team
not to go seven and nine again they're
used to 11 or 12. i mean look they've
got how many 12 win seasons i mean a lot
so they've got to put up some numbers
this year i think he's got to win 10. i
think he has to that's the number yeah
but they're playing 17. remember so he
goes 10 and seven this year let me get
some clarification maybe maybe i'm
helping the audience out here because uh
maybe i'm misunderstanding the question
but are you saying
that if belichick let's just say the
rest of his career he's not a young man
he let's just say he plays five years he
does not have five years coaches five
more years right he does not have one
other winning season
are you saying he now is no longer the
greatest coach of all time and then who
if if so then who now becomes the best
coach okay a i am 100
saying if he doesn't win this year he's
not the greatest coach of all time and i
will argue anybody forever on that there
is though uh then it's a hodgepodge then
you have a mix of guys from chuck noll
to bill walsh to to vince lombardi to
george hales to hell but he's won six
super bowls listen i'll go so far as to
say he's not even the best current coach
if he doesn't win big this year look i'm
not asking so much you want to be
regarded as one of the greatest if not
the greatest of all time win one c have
one winning season without tom brady he
did do that
um the winning eleven and five with uh
matt castle as the quarterback
yeah okay he's on the uh 100th
anniversary team too yeah i mean you
know well
by the way i'm not even like the hugest
bill belichick fan yeah but but what i
what i admire most about bill belichick
too is he's also done it in a couple
different eras and like with this with
the with the way the salary cap and team
construction
is such a big part of it
to to the point uh phil was making
earlier you know trading these some of
these guys that are still in their prime
uh richard seymour getting first round
draft picks then reloading uh
he got randy moss on the cheap that
panned out pretty well uh who else did
he trade chandler jones he traded early
uh
i'm trying to think who else i mean
there's someone every freaking year and
it is i mean for me just as a fan of
sports that becomes very annoying it
does you know and i'm you know with you
doing the fantasy stuff which i don't
i mean that has to be enough you don't
want any running back on i want nothing
to do with it but you know overall i am
with you
he does have to produce and at least get
past the first round i mean there has to
be something where we could say you know
what they were extremely competitive and
if not
yeah that mean there could be you know i
don't i wouldn't say he'd get fired or
anything like that but i definitely
he's not he's gonna catch hell and he's
gonna catch him and i think only for
himself because he'll always have the
wins and he'll always have the rings
right those will never go away he's
going to be in the hall of fame he's
going to be he already is one of the
greatest of all time but man it's teed
up right there for him with six super
bowl titles to be the greatest of all
time with no one arguing it how does he
do it
you
you take a young quarterback like mac
jones and and you know he's going to
have
a better roster this year because he had
three or four guys opt out last year
during the pandemic some of his better
defense i think they're more than that
they're like yeah but i mean some three
or four they're better yeah
so they're automatically going to be
good but that conference buffalo you
know uh the jets are going to be better
i'm not saying they're capable of
beating the patriots but the dolphins
are a better team on
you know than the patriots are so i
think he's got to j he's just got to
erase the doubt i'll even take away the
numbers just
eliminate the doubt from people like me
that say that you just have to do it
once and
brady went
away for one year and he did it he wins
it all yeah when you can't do any better
than that so there's no argument about
where he stands
hey thanks so much for checking out that
short clip from sports now with tom
zenner if you want to see another short
clip click right here or if you want to
see the entire episode click right here
thanks for watching everybody
[Music]